من المحتمل أن يكون أكثر متتبع لياقة بدنية شيوعًا
في السوق ، والآن
يمكن أن يساعدك Fitbit في التنبؤ بموعد الإصابة
بالأنفلونزا ومن خلال مشاركة البيانات ،
يمكن أن يساعد مسؤولي الصحة على توقع
تفشي المرض.
فيتبيت
باستمرار بين مارس 2016
ومارس 2018 في خمس ولايات راقبت
التغييرات ومتوسط معدل ضربات القلب وأ
ماط النوم لدى المستخدمين لتحديد متى يم
ن أن يصاب المستخدم با
أنفلونزا ويميل شخص يعاني من الأنفلونزا إلى ار
فاع معدل ضربات القلب والتغيرات في نم
النوم.  ثم
قارنوا البيانات بتقارير الإنفلونزا الأسبوعية في
ولاياتهم والتي وضعتها المراكز الأمريكية لمكافحة
الأمراض والوقاية منها ، وكانت
النتيجة أساسًا التنبؤ بالأنفلونزا في الوقت الفعلي
نظرًا لأن وقت الاستجابة هو المفتاح
عندما يتعلق الأمر بتفشي الأمراض
، ويأمل مؤلفو الدراسة أن يكون هذا ممكنًا.
تستخدم لتحسين وقت الاستجابة للمدن
والولايات للرد على تفشي الإنفلونزا عندما
تصبح التكنولوجيا  أكثر تقدمًا وربما
حتى الحصول على تحديثات يومية بدلاً من التحديثات الأسبوعية ،
يمكن أن تستغرق تقارير المراقبة التقليدية من أسبوع إلى ثلاثة أسابيع
مما يحد من القدرة على الاستجابة السريعة
للدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا
Reid Binion